alright guys thanks for coming out today
I'm filling in for avi Freidman he's on
a plane somewhere are you supposed to be
here by now but okay he's not here he'll
be here next week so today I'll be
giving the class and I watch a lot of
kids tournaments like I go to all the
beginner kids tournaments and there's
one mate that wins like every game and
that scholars mate has anyone heard of
scholars made so let's put it on the on
the board so we can all see alright so
most of you probably play e4 because
that's what kids play and then every kid
plays this move so this is all of your
guys's games every time but now most
people think you should play a good move
like develop a piece and attack upon but
what do they know they don't watch a lot
of kids tournaments where scholar mate
wins every game so sometimes you can
start with the bishop or with the Queen
so notice here the queen is attacking
upon all right it's attacking two pawns
so all right all right so here we go
so we're attacking upon so most people
like to develop pieces and they defend
all right and then we attack f7 again I
was cool enough I'd make it a color all
right so we put our Bishop here so now
we have two pieces on f7 so the big
mistake I see it all the tournaments is
people play here attacking the Queen
right and then they get checkmated so
this is scholars mate and when you go to
any kids tournament one kid will scholar
mate four people in a row and then he'll
be on board one and then he'll get
scholars mated and it's like you know
scholars mate you just did it to every
kid you played and then somehow you got
scholars made it so we don't want to
just know how to scholars mate we better
know how to not get scholars made it so
all right we'll see this is the advanced
class
so we'll see all right so these moves
were all fine depend upon all right so
now we need to suggest a better move
than Queen f6 who knows how to not get
scholars made it yeah
Queen to e7 a fine move that protects
the pawn the only right and the only
downside really is probably playable but
this poor Bishop said I kind of wanted
to come out here a little bit right
right so okay mmm so that move is
probably playable and fine most people
choose a different move and I know you
know what's the answer
all right get some help night on e7 this
one alright very interesting now most
people think you should checkmate and
some people think you should checkmate
this way so alright so that's not it
what should we do what should we do yeah
you know right which is g6 alright right
so this way we didn't we didn't get
checkmated which is the first goal
alright so now we're not done with our
little tricks
alright Queen f3 we got we got one more
chance right so we got the same threat
so some people I've seen this I've seen
it at least once go here hey it's a good
you're attacking a queen your attack in
the sea pond you're going to get a big
fork and then you know then the game
ends and you're like aww alright so
black says alright I'm not going to make
like random moves like you're going to
develop a piece and not get mated how
much you can Knight h6 right which is
okay there's only one problem that might
happen what might go here and you might
eventually take your knight and then
he'll threaten checkmate again but okay
perhaps perhaps you can get away with it
but most people like to put their night
on the most natural square possible
which is 9 f6 right fantastic so blacks
doing great he's a he's developing his
pieces you know he's he's gonna have a
fine game now if White's not careful
there's only one thing if you just make
some random move black does have a good
move here he can develop a knight and
now it's some people will play the worst
move ever as you'll see in our featured
game and then this will happen
so obviously the obviously the Queen
should just go back and protect c2 and
this is a theme we're going to see when
the Queen leaves you over here on this
diag
early that means at least she's leaving
the sea to pond and the black queen will
leave the c7 pond unprotected so we'll
see this theme in some of the games
today so because at the beginning of the
game that's that's her job protect this
pawn all right
so also this is the advanced class let's
see we're going to see one game where
white tries a little bit too hard to
attack f7 alright so we can try again we
can try again
now this is a game between my two
favorite players and N and nn
does anyone know what NN means right no
name right so they're not good enough to
have a name probably because they played
this bad move and now it looks like I'm
about to take the f7 pawn so you know
you might think oh you're in trouble you
better defend but actually black King
calmly as he did in the game play Knight
d4 so what's going on can we take this
pawn you'll take the Queen right check
so the computer won't let me take the
Queen
I can't cheat so black would calmly just
move a king what's the problem
and now does white have any we're good
to put this Queen right and if you go
too far away you know again your C pawn
so you got to stay where you can protect
your C pond and then you're going to
lose your bishop
so I suppose when this move was played
white must have seen that he said oh I
can't take on f7 all right so instead he
said alright I got to move my queen and
I got to protect my C pawn so alright
that move protects the C pawn and black
alright
so black got to get his pawn up to d5
you want to take white wanted to take
all right they're in our game and then
took that guy and black took antiques
and now most people are saying why don't
you just take this pawn but again black
wanted to attack this square here so
what move do you think he played to
attack see - yes right there what move I
want to attack see - again
do you know f6
what square is this f5 right all right
so now things are looking pretty good
we're going to take here so white plays
a very unfortunate move and I'm showing
you this game because there's a really
cool tactic here which was played so
when we played this move we opened up
that diagonal here is that enough you
know what's what's the all-star move but
I can I can take the C pawn check all
right
and then Queen takes whoops all right so
that didn't happen instead if we can
lure this Queen away if we can distract
her maybe we can take this pawn who sees
it yeah do you see it Wow very good
tactic right and now the white player
resigned he realizes if we take this
bishop he says alright free bishop
pretty good he loses c2 and it's a royal
fork that is this Knight is attacking a
king a queen and a rook right it doesn't
get much better than a Royal fork so
white saw that and after after this
awesome move white resigned okay all
right so we so we realize now in this
position after they block the mate we
shouldn't get too greedy we can't attack
it again
all right because then the knight comes
in and we remember the game okay now
sometimes you play people that don't get
scholars mated they see it and they
don't let you scholars made them and I
recently played this against the 600 in
one of our tournaments here and I'm over
three times higher rated than this guy
so I'm trying to play this and like I
want to win so also a few more mistakes
like for some reason every tournament I
this as well right which is a big
mistake and everyone sees why right okay
right to check and then for some reason
people do this and you take a look and
then for some reason they go here and
they say up trains Queens tripped and
you say thank you very much
now I've seen this position like three
four times in these tournaments so you
play this as what you might pick up a
lot of pieces really quick also a lot of
people play here which is not as bad as
it might seem because you know Black
gets pieces out [ __ ] castled right
away and your Queens still in the center
but you're up upon so you know the game
the game started continues and you play
chess all right well I was playing a 600
and he decided to defend this in a
creative way all right
he went here which is funny because I
brought my queen out too early and he
said hello
you're a lot higher rated that must be a
good idea I'll bring my queen out too
early right so all right yeah so what he
did now what was this Queen defending
when she was back here we all remember
c2 right yeah y'all you everybody means
c7 right okay so I bring my night out
and if I get another turn I'll attack a
queen and I'll go here alright so first
he attacks my queen alright so I don't
have time for this cuz he'll take my
queen so I got a move and there's a lot
of squares I can move to and we have two
player walking in the door that knows
where I should move my queen yeah e to
right so this is one of the two good
squares and I could have gone there the
only reason I didn't is you know I
probably want my bishop out here so
actually I went all the way back home
and it's funny I brought my queen out on
move - and now the question I'm saying
to black is why you got your queen out
so early right no wonder you're so low
rated you got your queen out there so
early right so right okay so and also in
a surprise twist now black has a threat
what's blacks threat
yeah
Bishop f2 check and then I'll have to
move my king right also strong is is
checkmate right so if it's his turn
he'll scholar make me alright so we got
yeah I'd be so embarrassed so we need to
not only know what we're scholar mating
people we got to see hey he's going to
scholar meet me so what like if I go
here what if I let him go here yeah well
then I shake his hand I say good game
and I go cry for a while cuz I just lost
right so I get a check right so what do
you guys think I would do here yeah
Knight f3 right developing piece is the
most natural square for the knight
alright excellent okay now he won here
and then I played a move none of you are
considering except the people that
already saw the game but you still know
people that already saw the game Origen
do you know Bishop e2 is fine and then I
Castle and we play a normal game but I'm
a lot higher rated so I wanted to do
cool stuff and try to win quickly so
yeah do you know Bishop b5 check and
this is I'm glad you said it because I
see a lot of my students do this and
then what tends to happen is you know
black will just attack my Bishop and
then I got to move it again somewhere
and this might help black because in the
future he might play d5 and I've kind of
helped him build his own Center the
night will be blocked in there are there
are some trade-offs you know yeah it
does block the knight in so it's you
know it's a little good a little bad you
know what is it right and you know what
square that is before a tricky move
right so he's thinking look what it must
be my birthday I get a free pawn he's so
excited so he took it all right down
upon all right I know I know at least
one guy sees my awesome move
do you know why did I give up my pond a
night
what night should I move can you kiss
you got a board round your seat you can
look on your seat d5
all right now I'm attacking a queen and
a bishop and a pond right so all right
so I'm feeling pretty good all right
guys all right guys right it must be my
birthday look at all this good stuff
right so he can't move his Queen
anywhere that will protect his bishop so
he's going to lose his bishop so he's
going to do what's called a desperado
who knows what a desperado is you know
right this bishop is is going to be out
of the game if he just moves his Queen
back I take the bishop right so he knows
he's losing the bishop so he does a
desperado he gives it away with check so
if you lose your piece you might as well
get two pawns for the piece instead of
just one all right so now you guys know
I'm attacking a queen and I'm attacking
c7 but he only realized I'm attacking a
queen and so he played like the worst
move possible right and do you know what
I played c7 all right and what is this
called look at this a king a royal fork
all right so he's in check I'm doing
pretty good now I'm feeling pretty
confident
all right now I think everybody should
know what move I played here
okay all right take the rook I can take
the rook and then I'll still win but I
want to win fast because he's a lot
lower rated so I'll take a queen
obviously okay
he used to develop a piece fantastic and
now people might notice that there's a
weak pawn on this board for black who
sees a really weak pawn
origin right d6 look so if this bishop
were off the board the only thing that
could protect is the king the King could
move to e7 and protect his pawn also if
it's blacks turn you know he might
develop a piece and right now I want to
make sure he doesn't get to do what he
wants to do so I need to get the bishop
out and I need to prevent a knight from
coming here right so let's see what
should I play yeah Bishop g5 right so
now I'm attacking this pawn and
preventing him from doing normal
development so he attacks me what should
I do sir retreat this looks like a good
square right what should I do
do you know right because it's check
alright fantastic so now the King has to
move and he went here all right looks I
got a pretty good square to retreat to
yeah oh all right so I'm just eating up
all of his central pawns but now he says
all right I got a fork a big fork now
since you're the advanced class I'm
going to ask the question should I do a
desperado or should I just take this
Bishop let's see
alright some people say take the bishop
who wants to do a desperado desperado
right so I can go there the trade-off is
then I we have he gets to develop a
piece so I'm up so much material here
I'm not really worried about getting
another pawn what I want to do is I want
to get all my pieces out and then I'll
have more pieces than him
I'll overwhelm him with all my pieces so
I just took the bishop and now since
it's the advanced class you know how
important time is in chess so now he has
to waste time taking back so now it's
it's my term and I still have the
initiative yes do you know what I did
right so this is the right idea this is
what I wanted to do and the reason is I
want to stop him from going here in this
rook stops and from going there because
then I get to put my rook here and now
my rook is really good and this King is
going to have to move yeah so that's
what I wanted but I decided to castle so
I get to choose I know my rooks going
here and I get to choose so I want my
King on e 1 or C 1 and now I'm thinking
of like the worst possible thing that
could ever happen to me if somehow he
gets his pieces out and he gets a rope
to the e-file he might be able to take
this pawn it's not going to happen but
just just in case I got my king over
here where he's a little bit safer all
right so now he can't really go here
because I'll check him you know what
black is going to do what's not going to
do
that's a good move I would resign too
but alright right so let's see let's see
what he did now I hope you guys would
like to velop pieces here but that's not
what he did and now I have a really good
move that ties up all of his pieces yeah
rook to d8 right over there a very good
move let's look right so he can't really
move this night cuz he'll lose a rook
right I'll take the rook with check I
can take the knight right so all none of
his pieces can move and I'm still
getting all of my pieces two better
squares also I'm threatening to just
take this night so he says are the only
way to protect is with the king so yet
not that not the best maneuver right so
we're not getting your pieces out you
can get a lot of trouble so what do you
guys think I should do here yeah in the
back I should do rook g8 Queen g8 and
then oh alright
so what I want to do if there's no I
can't really capture because it's
protected enough so I want to get more
pieces out so what should I do
Bishop c4 all right good right and then
you know I'm gonna get all my pieces out
and I have more pieces so if they all
come out I should have more pieces than
you now it's still very hard for him to
move he can't really continue his
maneuvering because then I'll take care
and also he realizes if he does nothing
I'll still take care so instead of doing
that he said well I better try going
here right now if I want I can take the
rook well you'll notice my work is doing
a very good job I don't have it I wish
how do I highlight I need to I need some
control click
I just did control right click all right
all right doesn't matter through shift
oh my goodness all right so I'll you'll
see how how good my rook is so this King
doesn't have a lot of places to go so I
want to use my queen to to attack all
these you know there we have a seventh
rank the eighth rank and it's going to
tough so uh so I got three moves Jango
here why not okay right well we're right
here yes yes all right so I went here
and right it's a good move so now his
King can't really go anywhere so all he
can do is block alright so some people
see check me all right he's got one move
take the rook check mate all right
fantastic all right let's see if we got
any more good games all right all right
here's a game I played a while ago when
I was when I was new to scholar meeting
people so this is a game I played
against a fellow coworker so we won't we
won't mention his name but all right so
I went there all right so he defended
his pawn right good good first step all
right so and then who thinks he went
here and I want quickly right now I of
course that so he's pretty good so he
didn't let me do it alright I'll try
again
alright and he played the best move he
developed a piece now I know from that
other game that I shouldn't play this
move and I also know this Knight kinda
wants to go here so in this position I
developed a night and now I'm deterring
him from putting a knight on d4 because
I'll take it and then
No all right and it'll be a trade okay
now in the game I played against the 600
he put his Bishop out here which breaks
one of my rules and I have a one door
policy if you move this pawn then this
bishop should come out this way and if
you move a jeep on your Bishop should
come out here because when he my other
opponent put his Bishop out here all the
dark squares by his King side were
really weak and then I you know bad
things happened but all right but my
opponent decided all right I'll keep my
Bishop kind of where he belongs I played
g6 I better put my Bishop on g7 all
right all right I prepare to get more
pieces out and he castles all right and
there's a lot of lot of good moves here
so I just I just develop more pieces and
you'll play here now there's something
you do kind of have to watch out for in
this variation and that is this bishop
usually does really good when he comes
here so I wanted to prevent that so I
played h3 alright now now he played he
said all right he notices this pawn and
he doesn't want to go here because I'll
take him so he went here and now it's my
turn to make a bad move I wanted to just
play here but then I thought he would go
here and he wants to trade bishops and
then take here but if you put this on
computer it says all right what's the
problem he can't trade bishops but I
didn't see that so there's other bad
moves I like to play I like to play
queen h5 which is the bad move and
there's another bad move I always play
that's King d1 right so now I'm not
going to castle but I'm going to attack
over here on the Kings side and pretend
like my King belongs there
who likes the move King d1 all right we
got one one hand all right that's
probably the appropriate number of hands
because it's not fantastic but they're
all right it's not the end of the world
let's see so he
played here which if my kings in the
center he should probably hurry up to
open up some files in the center but uh
but I just developed I attack the knight
and then I went back all right so now
it's my turn I got I got one more piece
to get out so I got it out over here all
right
h6 so I can retreat or I can trade I can
ignore and lose a piece take the pawn I
can take upon lot of stuff trade all
right so I didn't really want to trade
my Bishop for a knight because as you
get better you realize bishops are a
little bit better than Knights we're all
told that it's 3/3 and then all the kids
tournaments like everybody loses all
their pieces so it doesn't really matter
but I wanted to keep my Bishop and also
now that I've induced this weakness
maybe maybe somehow in the future I'll
attack it with a queen or something all
right so I didn't trade and then he went
here so a bit slow he went here and then
here all right I went here and I'm
hoping for this move what yeah why am i
hoping for this move Arjen right a fork
okay so if he wants to take this you'll
have to take with a bishop but he
probably doesn't want to do that all
right so he played here and I assume he
wants to play here and attack my bishop
so uh all right here comes here comes my
attack here comes all right and so he
played b5 now when people attack my
stuff the first question I ask is how
can I ignore it right so I don't want to
move my bishop I want to say your
threats aren't as good as mine so I
didn't move my bishop I didn't move it
so I better make a threat that's at
least as great as taking a piece so what
move do you guys think I played in the
back
right so this would work too because
it's check so I thought about it and
then he would take back and you know I
can trade bishops I thought about it but
I again like most of my opponents I play
this again so I was a lot higher rated
so I didn't really want to trade any
pieces instead I played g5 also with my
King on d1 I kind of wanted to play for
maximum confusion cuz you know my king
is here
alright so took my bishop which is okay
and I took his Knight
alright and he played here and then
should I take a bishop or a pawn bishop
and you'll take here with check and then
something something will take I can
castle castle Castle kingside
now I'm on the D file so that's not how
Castle where's all right instead I took
here because I want you to have your
next move to be moving this Bishop
somewhere so sure that happened
alright so this happened I took back and
now he surprised me I guess so I guess
it is
cuz that bishop is still hanging all
right thank you and then he surprised me
again like it looks like I'm going to
take this rook with check because I am
and so he surprised me again
I guess he's saying you're attacking my
rook I'm attacking yours so what do you
think I did take the rook
all right and now it may make a
difficult choice here Queen all right I
made a queen you can make a rook - all
right right so he took so now I'm up
like a lot of pieces what happened okay
so his threat is to take my rook so
obviously I'm not going to move my rook
that's my style if so he's attacking
something I want to say how can I do
anything but move my rook so what do you
think I played how do I make a threat
that's this greater or equal to him
taking my rook that's a pretty big
threat so let's see ya in the middle
yeah and the red Knight seven I take
here all right check and then I'm like
oh I lost my rook all right I moved this
Knight but I went to this square which
is check okay so he moved and now I
can't really find anything better I was
trying to like make crazy stuff work but
all right let's just let's just save our
rook all right all right so now I guess
this was this big point was he got to
check in all right but that right my
king will be safer over here so you know
just keep checking me over here all
right
in comes a knight right he's attacking
my queen
right now taking it is too obvious
all right so I actually played this move
oh oh all right everyone's like oh he's
like all right he's like all right I
accept what was my point
do you know rook g1 that's what I played
and he went here and now my Queens
attacked Knight takes Knight Knight
takes Knight all right you guys don't
like my move all right that's what I did
bishop why all right if you're gonna say
bishop tell me why right actually I
wanted to use this bishop because
somehow if I want to meet him I'm going
to need my queen up here and I might
need to take this this pawn with check
so I took with the night and then when
he took back all right so I'm doing good
my rooks here I got the G file somehow I
want it I want to checkmate let's see
take take the rook if you're black I
have to take this rook right I do want
this rook gone because then it's easy I
take on f7 but that's going to be hard
because this guy's not going to go
anywhere and if he does then I'm gonna
lose my rook on on the C file so but I
need a nice forceful move who sees a
good move Arjun
right see you you almost had the whole
game right check check and now the move
you missed was he resigned so so good
calculation right obviously if King h7
then Queen g7 is check me all right very
very good you saw the whole thing all
right so now when you guys go to another
kids tournament I hope you're the one
that skull are mating everybody and I
hope you never get scholars mated so
we're going to practice now and I want
to see a lot of skull our mates on all
these boards alright thanks guys